mentioned the sunrise event over at the
Clark County Government Center in the
amphitheater also there this weekend
tomorrow it's the Remember music
festival a special country music tribute
to mark five years since when October
and money raised will of course go to
the permanent one October Memorial being
planned down at the site of the tragedy
joining me this morning Country Strong
founder Shawna Bartlett and Connie long
thank you for joining us this morning to
talk about this uh this event which has
actually been going on for several years
now since the tragedy but this is the
first time that really the public can
take part in something why did you guys
feel the need to really expand what this
country music festival is for
when we started planning um and we knew
that the money was going to go to the
permanent Memorial
that's when we knew we needed and wanted
the community involved and we wanted
them to feel like they were a part of
this and they could somehow contribute
to the memorial even though they may not
have been at the concert but we wanted
them to feel like they were a part of it
and they could be a part of it and I I
one interesting I think we should also
talk about is that you you guys how you
became connected obviously through the
tragedy of course and what has happened
for you in the five years since one
October so we met let's see one month
after the shooting and we started
planning events in our different states
and then we came together and kind of
decided that we needed to do something
for everybody and we planned a one-year
um then we called it a reunion and then
it just kind of developed after that so
the first year was we had about 2 000
people and then the next year was at one
of the local hotels and then covet came
so we we went to a park and then
Stoney's helped us out last year and
they're again helping us this year make
this just the biggest event yet
why is it important to have such a big
event like this
it's important to keep the story alive
it's important to keep honoring the 58
that didn't make it home that night and
it's important to keep sharing
I feel that we've had over 600 mass
shootings since one October and they all
just kind of quietly go away and I just
feel that there's an opportunity to
learn things from each one and keeping
them alive keeps the story out there
yeah and certainly we I mean not a day
goes by that I don't drive by the
healing Garden think about it every day
for those who want to go to the event
downtown just tickets uh who's going to
be there what should people expect
uh tickets can be purchased at
remembermusicfest.com our headliner is
going to be Midland and we have six
other artists Dylan Schneider who was
also at route 91. and yeah Dylan yeah so
Dylan Schneider in both Midland we're at
Route 91 Dylan Schneider actually
performed on Sunday in the next
Nashville stage on one October and then
we have Seth Innis we have drew green we
have Walker Montgomery and Morgan
Patrick and shotgun Jefferson is a local
band out of California that will be
opening and singing our national anthem
for us it's a great event I wish we had
more time to chat it's good to see both
of you again I'm glad that everyone can
take part the money goes to such a great
cause again they're a member of Music
Festival at the Clark County
Amphitheater it is tomorrow after the
sunrise Ceremony be there at one o'clock
both of you thank you for coming in this
morning appreciate it thank you